[ __ ] porn i call it but yeah
i call it yeah that's the greatest thing
ever and you can say that because you're
into it love it i love it bro i watch
this why do you like you know explain
what the chili that's my girl on the
mouth [ __ ]
right after i come i can't him right in
the mouth though
derek's girl is here by the way we gotta
get her perspective okay
you don't want to call her samantha you
want to call her
[Laughter]
sometimes i call her sampson
[Laughter]
why why tr now we've talked about this
before but
why
why do you love training porn so much it
is we all watch porn and it's the best
of both worlds it is the reason we
always use your hands like it's art well
because
two reasons for both genders
basic with the guy he's got to be in
shape
and he's gotta have a leg of a dick
period you don't want to see no meat no
one might was no jiggling and you don't
see no small dick period point blank
with the woman she's got to be a bad
[ __ ] fat ass nice titties and [ __ ]
porn has found a way
to like dragon ball z go tanks that [ __ ]
and and fuse the best of both worlds
okay so you got so you got
a big titties
good shape but also big dick huge uh a
small dick that's gay i don't watch that
so
if she's got a small dick i'm like get
this little dick [ __ ] out of here bro
you're not even a woman
you're not even a [ __ ] woman
with that dick
of a woman bro with your soft ass
no bro you gotta be hard dick legged
titties out and a bad [ __ ] and i'm i'm
all in
[Music]
men are done bro
[Laughter]
so
so if there's a guy for example that's
into training porn but it's with smaller
dicks what do you think about them
that's [ __ ] gay bro you want to see
small who wants to watch porn and see a
flaccid small dick a flashlight small
thing is kind of disgusting yeah yeah
when you see it on camera it's [ __ ]
disgusting and you see it like
getting [ __ ] and it's flopping it's
like i'm already gross now
you make that [ __ ] this
little different and it looked like this
now i'm like wow this is
artistic this is kind of beautiful like
when you see those paintings and you
know what i mean like of the naked
people yeah yeah like this is beautiful
now how did you break this down to to
your girl
i told her hey i like training for her
actually no she saw me go on stage once
and
it was like 30 minutes of me talking
about how great it was
and she was just like oh that's what you
want to say sam that's when you found
out
yeah
she found out she thought one night i
was like that's what he's doing
because she knows i'm in that bathroom
bro but you know that's my time
i let her watch her shows when she's
watching bridgette i don't say [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i don't say a [ __ ] word
that's dude well yeah but at least the
shower watch is good
the [ __ ] i watch get views i mean
bridgewater gets views but not the views
i'm talking about wait what kind of
numbers you put up i'm talking [ __ ] 25
mil everything
he's watching everything he's watching
mrs beast
oh
i believe i've watched a trans woman
[ __ ] a woman that's what he likes i
think
i like that too no no no no
no
two women that's a lesbian i i need
another man and this woman so he i
believe them bro i believe in trey i
believe them they're women
i have to believe you pick it back
okay
look i got it
oh yeah i guess that's just like like
that's that's straight but there's just
more tits it's the same [ __ ] more time
he likes i've never struggled with
mental math so much in my life
go go go go go go go tell me what it is
what are all the parts what are all the
parts it's who's yeah
i like a male that is not a man a porn
star a dude yeah in shape huge dick
[ __ ] a beautiful woman with a vagina
resting on top with a dick resting on
top with eight big titties and also a
huge dick and that is the kind of porn
that i start my day with wait so there's
two dicks in this scene yeah a man and a
woman
[Music]
y'all
because
that is gross and gay it has to be a
beautiful woman just like all porn has
to be a beautiful woman
she also has to have
a gigantic penis but why
because that's really because i i
believe in women
i believe in their rights to have fun
and do whatever they want in their
rights oh i'm sorry al doesn't believe
in human rights
apparently i don't what do you mean you
can come up
if it's a beautiful woman right
everything about her is a woman
everything's beautiful and then you get
down to the [ __ ] but instead of a [ __ ]
it's a baton
that's weird to you but you got so many
options though on like to pull up
there's white ones and black ones and
asian ones
all kinds of options well we said huge
dick asians out the window
i've seen it yeah they're up
so wait out that would be weird for you
it's just not my cup of tea of porn have
you watched it let's say for example
you're seeing a straight porn star male
1
suck a beautiful women's huge dick
i'm cool even samuel into that that's
kind of hot
it ain't gabriel you sucking a woman's
dick that's as straight as you can do it
that's the straightest way to suck dick
i think
maybe that's maybe i'm crazy
maybe i'm crazy
of straight ways to do it
bro i'm always right
i'm always right i'm good at everything
has this created any issues in your guys
relationship is there do you ever worry
sam about uh uh
not being able to fulfill his desire
yeah you don't have enough dick for this
guy
no no no i hope i can't fulfill his
desires i'd rather him you know wear
himself out in the
morning oh you need it too much
so you need it too much yes you need a
nut every single day i nut oh yeah twice
a day minimum minimum bare minimum and
in the other days depending on the day
how much time i have and how much fun
the day has been yeah comics bro wow and
i support that yeah and you support what
do you mean by you support that like
you keep nothing
bro come out the bathroom relax chill i
hug her i don't attack her so he's been
questioned questions
in the morning dawg she knows what it is
question this might be a little too much
but then would you prefer
if she wears a strap on no that's gay
yeah why are you making a game making it
so gay
finally thank you i'm
because it recreates that scene what oh
the strap on no but yeah he doesn't want
to get no i'm fine no i'm not saying he
he's getting [ __ ] but just she just
wears it just for the heck of it
that's weird it's not it's like a bat
in the room
you can get a black one i want flesh
what if sam said i want to get a surgery
so that i can have a penis
yeah yeah you got to help her pick out
the penis ooh
it would at least be a discussion
[Laughter]
no i gotta have no cause i gotta have
babies that's the problem the this is
the real problem ladies the moment we
really learn
how to impregnate these [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you're extinct dinosaurs
dinosaur [ __ ] all of you bro you
think i'm not putting a baby in that
[ __ ] thing this is the [ __ ]
hand-eye coordination he'll have and the
the balance so you're saying vaginas are
like flip phones so we're just waiting
for the technology
bro elon [ __ ] twitter [ __ ] figure out
how we can put
[Laughter]
so
what you're saying is
if sam could have a penis and still
produce a child oh my god
you know
you know what's that roll of stone you
can't always get what you want
guys thank you so much for watching that
flagrant 2 clip but before you go i got
to tell you about blue chew you need to
deliver the woman you care about the
best dick that you can possibly give her
and the way you're going to do that is
with blue chew you don't want to be like
certain djs out here find out you've
been married to a girl for 10 years and
then she never came no you cannot do
that so get blue chew give her the best
dick you can possibly give her and the
way you do that is by going to
bluechew.com and entering the promo code
andrew and they will give you your first
order for free all you gotta do is pay
five dollars shipping again that is
bluechew.com promo code andrew now go
watch another flag in two clips